trump campaign just released an ad it's
sort of an ad i guess
it's produced by the trump campaign and
it's a sort of mock
you know true crime show
that's just making fun of all those sad
senile aspects of joe
my name's joe biden i'm a democratic
candidate for the united states senate
corn pop was a bad dude
i'm not going nuts you'd be the oldest
president in american history
all right chuck thank you very much uh
it's chris but anyway
it would put 720 million back
in the workforce we choose truth over
facts
hello and welcome to the first episode
of what we call
truth over facts today we're examining
the curious case of sleepy joe
and you know the thing our investigation
begins
at a recent campaign stop in texas
join us next time when we will work with
a renowned sketch artist who will reveal
who or what is a lying dog-faced pony
soldier
oh man what a great what a great
series i hope there really are more of
these it plays
it plays to so many important points one
trump and the trump campaign certainly
gets the country okay do you remember a
few weeks ago there was the lincoln
project as a group of
uh disgruntled former republicans who
hate donald trump
and conservatism apparently any
conservative policies
and so they they ran this big ad
campaign called
mourning in america but it was
m-o-u-r-n-i-n-g
it's donald trump is really bad it's
mourning in america he's really bad
don't vote for trump trump you know it
just it seemed like an
ad from 90s tv not like an ad from
2020 digital culture well this is the
opposite of that right
what what the trump campaign realizes is
that stuff's so dated it's so played out
people want to be entertained a little
bit they don't want this to be a scary
ad they don't want it to club them over
their head
they want it to entertain them a little
bit ronald reagan was very good at
entertaining people donald trump very
good at entertaining people
and true crime just as a genre of
entertainment is
is almost certainly the most popular one
in the whole country when you look at
podcasts true crime shoots to the top of
the charts
people love those true crime shows and
so it's a mock true crime show
making fun of joe biden look no one's
afraid of joe biden
certainly none of our foes around the
world but no one in the united state of
joe biden okay they can say oh yeah he's
creepy with women and
okay whatever no nobody we've known joe
for a long time
it's fine he's and now he's a sort of
frail older gentleman
so really no one's afraid the real
attack is
he's a joke make him into a joke and
laugh at him it's going to have a much
much more damaging effect on him
in 2020. so that's how he goes after
biden
he goes after in a similar way nancy
pelosi even off the cuffs you remember
the other day
nancy pelosi referred to donald trump as
morbidly obese
in this gratuitous comment on a
television show so trump was asked about
that
and he uh he just swatted her away last
night nancy speaker of the house against
pelosi called you
overly obese i just wanted to know what
you had to say in response oh i don't
respond to her i think she's a waste of
time
these people are sick pelosi is a sick
woman it's got a lot of problems a lot
of mental problems
we're dealing with people that have to
get their act together for the good of
the country
okay thank you very much i like this
i like this kind of response i mean i
wish we lived in a time
it would be much better if we lived in a
time where people had civility and grace
and just
sort of really witty repartee we don't
okay we don't that's not the time that
we live in
we're not going to have sort of
churchillian zingers going back and
forth necessarily or
some kind of really elevated speech this
is the
kind of world we're living in and if
we're living in this world i want donald
trump to be on my side
uh nancy pelosi calls you fat oh yeah i
think she's crazy
now it seems like a tit-for-tat but it's
not really because what pelosi did was
go
for this kind of physical issue that
trump has
that a lot of people have namely being a
little overweight
who do you know that isn't a little
overweight right i mean this is america
for goodness sake everybody's a little
bit overweight
so that doesn't play as well you go for
a physical thing
that describes virtually everybody
what trump does is then go for a mental
thing
the men which doesn't describe everybody
no very few people in this country as
crazy as nancy pelosi
but he goes for that mental thing
because that is psychological that is
what is
that is using your faculties of reason
that is
what we're really doing when we engage
in politics right we're dealing with
issues
the leaders of this country are using
their minds and their brains hopefully
to guide ourselves doesn't matter what
they look like necessarily winston
churchill was a big fat guy too
so no one i don't think uh that was like
a real knock against him
and so i think trump is focusing on the
more important thing here
now what that means into 2020 who knows
i think that the left knows that they're
really not looking good pelosi's not
playing well
joe biden's certainly not playing well
so you're going to hear a lot more
shenanigans about mail-in voting
they're going to probably try to
minimize the conventions
and republicans would be crazy to let
them do it we should have a big
showing for these conventions we should
make sure people show up to vote
because i think when people are engaging
with the reality of this campaign
in the reality of uh voting you know
real real life in person
i don't think it's going to go very well
for the left
you